hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today today
let's solve another
classic dynamic programming problem coin
change
and we get a pretty simple uh
description so we're given a list of
coins
of different values and we're also given
a total amount
of money that we want to sum up to but
we
want to use the fewest number of coins
possible to make up or to sum up to that
amount
and it's possible that that amount of
money cannot be made up
with any combination of the coins that
we have
and then we want to return negative one
if that's the case and
luckily for us we're actually given an
infinite number of each coin so
in the first example we have coins of
value 1
2 and 5 and we have infinite quantities
of these coins the amount that we want
to sum up to
is 11 and basically you know just look
at this
what's the fewest number of coins we
could do well
of course we want to use a five because
it's the biggest one we can use another
five
and then we just need a one left if we
want to sum up to 11.
so in this case you can see we only
needed three coins
these this is the fewest number of coins
we needed so we can return
three in the second example we have a
coin of value two
but we want to sum up to three we can
try two plus two but we know that's
four so we went over three so there's no
way to
possibly sum up to three so we return
negative one there's no possible
solution
so your first idea might be can we just
be
greedy is the problem that easy can we
just
be greedy and let's look at this example
so let's say these are our coins one
three
four five and we want to sum up to seven
so when i say greedy i mean okay we
wanna sum up to seven let's just start
at the biggest coin we have
so let's start at five so now let's look
at the biggest coin again
five if we add a five here we know we're
going over
we're going over the total amount seven
right so we don't add another five
well let's look at the four well we know
five plus 4 is
also going to be more than 7 5 plus
3 is going to be more than 7. okay but
we found a 1. luckily we have a 1. so
let's add 1 to it now we're at
6. so let's add a second one
now we got to the sum seven so we
basically went down
from the biggest smallest coin values
right that's what i mean when i say
greedy let's pick the biggest one
possible
first so notice that this took us
three coin values right so our result in
this case would be three but
is that the minimum amount of coins the
answer is
no because you know just looking at it
we can tell
we got a three and we have a
four three plus four is seven
that means the minimum amount of coins
is actually
two so this is a counter example we
cannot be
greedy if we want to solve it so the
next thing you might try is like a brute
force solution right so to do the brute
force solution we need to implement
some kind of depth first search or
backtracking solution
right so let's look at the same example
one three four
five and amount sum to seven so what
would a backtracking solution
even look like for this problem well
it's gonna be brute force right so
so we have four coin values so that
means in our decision tree we have four
possible choices
we can choose a one we can choose a
three
we can choose a four or we can choose a
five
in this case the remaining amount would
be six
because seven minus one is six in this
case the remaining amount that we have
to compute
would be four because we're taking seven
minus three which is the coin that we
chose
so we get four as the remaining amount
right
in this case we would have a three and
in this case we would have a remaining
amount of
two so since none of these are zero
once we get to zero we know that that
we've computed
the total amount that we want but right
now we have to continue going right we
have to continue doing the brute force
approach
let's start at this side right now so we
still have
four coins right we have unlimited
quantity so we can choose
the coin one we can choose a three we
can choose a four
or we can choose a five if we choose a
one we'll have a remaining amount of
one if we choose a three we're going to
get a
negative one what does that tell us that
tells us
if we chose a five coin and we chose a
three coin
then we get to a negative value that
means
five plus three cannot be the amount
so we don't have to keep searching here
we can stop right we got to a negative
value
if we keep adding values to it it's just
going to become more and more
negative right and you can probably
notice that
since these values are even greater 2
minus 4 is going to be negative 2
2 minus 5 is going to be negative 3. so
we can't go down these paths either we
don't have to
search them anymore and so now here
we're gonna see
okay we can choose a one coin of course
we can choose a
three four and five but we can see from
here
that that's not gonna work that's gonna
lead us to a negative
value anyway if we choose a one
over here then we know we're going to
finally get to a zero
so this is what we want right we took a
five
from up here we took a one from over
here
and we took a third one right so then if
we
count how many coins we chose
down this path we know we get three
coins right
and we get to a zero so of course we
don't have to keep searching anymore
so we found one possible way where we
can
sum up to the amount seven we know it
has three coins which
you know from the previous example we
know that that's not the minimum amount
of coins
but we found an algorithm that at least
tells us
a possible solution so we can kind of
keep track of that the minimum coins
we can set to three so now i'm gonna
show you what happens when we go down
this tree path
even though we know that the solution is
actually three plus four which is two
coins
which either of these is gonna get us to
the correct solution i'm gonna show you
what happens when we go down
this one anyway so we can choose a coin
one
three four or five so if we go down this
path
we will have a remaining amount of five
here we'll have a remaining amount of
three
two here we'll have a remaining amount
of 1. do you kind of see how we're
taking
the original problem which is 7
and then breaking it down into sub
problems
like 6 and then breaking it down even
further into five and not only that we
have sub problems yes
but do you also see that these sub
problems are repeating themselves here
we have a remaining amount of
one here we also have a remaining amount
of one
so do we even have to compute this path
because we already know if we have an
amount one
it takes only a single coin
for us to be able to reduce it to the
amount
zero which is what we're looking for so
since
this sub problem repeats i don't have to
compute it
i can just borrow from over here
so in that case we see the same thing
happened though
we use a coin one and we get zero and we
see that okay it took
three coins for us to get to zero right
we took a one
a five and another one from over here so
basically we got the same thing that
happened
over here just in a different order and
just to make this a little less messy
i'm just gonna tell you that none of
these are going to lead us to the
optimal solution
so now let's look at this case we have a
remaining amount of four
how many coins does it take for us to
get an amount for well let's brute force
it let's check
every possible combination here we'll
get a
one here we'll get the value we're
looking for zero that's great but let's
just look at this last one
with five we'll get a negative one
meaning we can stop
searching so this is awesome we got a
zero and let's count how many coins did
it take us to
get to this zero we took one four and we
took a
three so this path is only
two coins long we see our minimum is
currently
three but we can actually replace this
now with a
two because two is the minimum number of
coins
needed to total to amount seven
so we know this is the correct answer
but let's just see what happens with the
remaining stuff
so first let me just look at this one we
see we actually
already solved this sub problem over
here
so we don't really need to solve it
again we know it takes
one coin for us to go from one to zero
and what about this three okay well we
can do
the same thing right one three four
five and i'll just tell you from here
we're not going to find the optimal
solution going from
four to three and more that's going to
obviously be more
than the current minimum of coins that
we have which is two right now
so this is not going to lead us to the
correct solution
but you see that once we compute
this stuff then we have one last
subtree over here right this original
three
but once we already solved the sub
problems of this
do we really have to solve the sub
problems here
no if we store it in memory if we have
like a cache
or you can call it dp we do not have to
repeat these sub
problems so the way i just solved this
was called top down or top down
memoization
because we're doing it recursively but
you can actually solve this
with a true dynamic programming solution
which
is bottom up and it means exactly what
it says so
bottom up basically instead of
solving the original problem where the
amount is seven we
solve it in reverse order we start at
the smallest one which is
zero right this zero over here so we
wanna know what's the minimum number of
coins
we can call it dp of zero so
for amount equals zero what's the
minimum number of coins
for us to sum to zero
well we know it just takes zero coins
right
what about if we wanna know what's the
minimum number of coins
for summing to one well we can
look at our coins we got a one a three a
four and a five
these will all cause it to be greater
than one but we just want a
one so we can take just this meaning it
only takes us
one coin to sum to 1. and then we can
just repeat that process right so for
a dp of 2 so we want how many coins
does it take for us to sum to 2 well
we got 4 coins right these 3 will cause
it to be greater than two so we don't
use those
but what about this one okay we get a
one
so it takes one coin to sum to one but
that's something we already
knew so if we want to compute dp
of two we can take one
plus dp of one
because we know these three coins are
going to be too
big but we have a one over here
that's value one and we also know
that that's not enough right two minus
one
still leaves us with a remaining amount
of one but we just computed that
up here we know for us to get the
minimum number of coins
to get a value one it only takes
one coin so that means that if we want
to get amount two it takes at least two
coins
and let's say we repeat this process for
all values for all amounts from
from all the way starting at zero all
the way
to seven over here so i computed it from
all the way from zero to six but the
last one we really
really want is amount equals seven so
let's compute that
dp of seven how do we get it
well we still kind of have to check
every single coin so
what happens if we get coin one
then we are com then we take the result
of one meaning that's how many coins we
use not the value one
because we needed one coin with a value
one and now we have a remaining amount
of
six right dp of six so how many coins
did it take
for us to compute dp of six well we
already computed that it took
two so we get one plus two
equals three so that's one possible
solution but is it the minimal solution
well let's look at if we use the coin
value three over here well it takes us
one coin so we take one plus
dp of four because that's the remaining
amount we have to use
if we take a coin value of three and
lucky luckily we already computed dp
of four it is one so then we get one
plus
one equals two and we know that
this is the real result that we want
but even before we know that we would
repeat this
process so technically if we do the
bottom-up
dynamic programming solution we are
going to repeat this for the remaining
two coins so for four we would get one
so we'd have one plus dp of three
because four
minor because seven minus four would
leave us with a remaining amount of
three
and in that case we know dp of three is
one so we would have the total of two
again so we see that there are actually
two solutions
and we know we have one last coin that
we technically have to check
coin five so we'd use one coin for value
five
and then the remaining amount we'd wanna
compute is dp of 2
and we know that dp of 2 is value 2 so
this would result in a
3 which is not what we want right so
from these 4 values that we computed
we want to take the minimum which we
know is 2
so we can return 2 in this case
so that took us forever but luckily the
code is a lot shorter so just like we
showed i'm gonna have a dp array and
i'm gonna initialize this to be
length of amount plus one because
we are going from zero
all the way to amount and the default
value i'm gonna give each uh element in
this array is amount
plus one or you can do like
infinity or whatever the max in is like
math.max integer or whatever
in your language but amount plus one is
basically a max value
anyway and we know that the base case
for this
is a dp of zero meaning if we want to
compute
amount zero that it only takes zero
coins
and now we're going to start computing
every value in dp
so for every amount a in
range and we're going to do this in
reverse order not
or rather bottom up so we're gonna go
from one
all the way to the amount and we
technically
are still doing it in a brute force way
so we
are gonna go through every coin so for
coin
in our list of coins so we're trying to
compute
this a amount so we're gonna take
a and subtract the current coin that
we're looking at
if this is non-negative
so if it's greater than or equal to zero
that means we can
kind of continue searching right so this
means
we possibly found a solution for our dp
so for this amount a we're going to set
it to the minimum
of itself and 1
plus dp of a
minus c so this 1 comes
from this current coin that we're using
c and dp of
a minus c comes from for example
let's say our coin value was four
and our amount that we're trying to
compute a is
seven basically we're saying dp of
seven is equal to one
plus dp of
three because seven minus four
is three so we're saying that this is a
possible solution
and actually that's the only thing that
we have to do
this is basically it this is like what's
called the recurrence relation
and so now the only thing we have to do
is return what we're looking for so dp
of amount so this is what we have to
return but
we remember one last edge case if we
could not compute the amount
meaning if so we can only return this
if if the value that's stored
is not the default value so if it's
not equal to amount plus one right which
was the default value that we
gave it so we'll return this if it's not
the default value
otherwise we're gonna have to return
negative one meaning we could not
compute this amount with the given coins
so this solution does work and even
though
it's pretty efficient the time
complexity is actually
big o the amount that we're given
multiplied the number of
coins that we're given and the memory
complexity is
big o amount because we see we have a dp
array that we're having a potential
value for every single
amount so i hope this was helpful if you
enjoyed
please like and subscribe it supports
the channel a lot and i'll hopefully
see you pretty soon